[موسيقى] هذه المشاهد من الأيام الأخيرة دفعت صوت أمريكا الأعلى في تفشي فيروس كورونا إلى إصدار تحذير صارم بشأن القضبان Boz ليست جيدة حقًا ليست جماعة الله في حانة بالداخل هي أخبار سيئة ، لقد توقفنا فعلاً عن ذلك في تكساس حيث ارتفع ارتفاع فيروس كورونا إلى مستويات خطيرة بشكل مقلق ، اعترف حاكم الولاية جريج أبوت أنه ارتكب خطأ بإعادة فتح ولايته إذا كان بإمكاني العودة وإعادة أي شيء كان من المحتمل أن يؤدي إلى إبطاء فتح القضبان الآن في أعقاب مدى سرعة ذلك انتشر فيروس كورونا في إعداد البار وفيك تعرف كيف أن شريط الجلوس في الواقع لا يعمل مع جائحة ، لكن أبوت وولايته ليسوا وحدهم بالتأكيد. التي إما أغلقت القضبان بالكامل أو أغلقتها جزئيًا أو أوقفت إعادة فتحها مؤقتًا ، يقول الخبراء إن الحانات المزدحمة وحدها لا تفسر الارتفاعات الأخيرة ، لكنهم يقولون إن  الجو الاجتماعي الطبيعي في
الحانات خطير بشكل خاص ، الحانات هي
الأماكن التي لا يرتدي
فيها الأشخاص أقنعة ، الأماكن التي يكون فيها الناس
متباعدون اجتماعيًا وبعد بعض المشروبات
بالطبع تفقد موانعك فيك
حتى أو أقل وعيًا بالأطباء الذين
تحدثنا إليهم يقولون أنه لا توجد طريقة تقريبًا
جعل إعداد شريط داخلي آمنًا أثناء
هذا الوباء في الداخل ، كما يقولون ،
خاصةً إذا كانت هناك موسيقى صاخبة يتم تشغيلها
في حانة ، فهذا يشبه طبق بتري
لانتشار الفيروس داخل الشريط إذا
كان هناك ضوضاء إذا كانت هناك
موسيقى تشغل الضوضاء المحيطة ستحدث  أنت
تتحدث بصوت أعلى عندما تتحدث بصوت أعلى ، فإنك
تطرد المزيد من القطرات من فمك ،
يمكن أن تحتوي هذه القطرات بالطبع على
الفيروس وتصيب الآخرين
جزءًا آخر مما يسمى بالعاصفة المثالية من
العدوى ، ويقول الخبراء إنه متوسط
العديد من الأشخاص الذين يذهبون إلى الحانات  إنهم يشعرون بأنهم
لا يقهرون لأنهم صغار ،
وبصراحة تامة طوال
بداية هذا الوباء ، فقد كان في الغالب
رسائل حول الأشخاص الأكبر سنًا و  الأشخاص الذين
يعانون من ظروف صحية موجودة مسبقًا على أنها
معرضة للخطر ، لذا فإن هذا الوباء
كان مشهد البار تمامًا ،
لا يعتقد الخبراء الطبيون الذين تحدثنا
إليهم أنه يعتقد أنهم يعتقدون أن الحانات المزدحمة التقليدية
ستعود ، لكنهم يقولون إن ذلك
لا يمكن أن يكون حتى ننتهي  لقاحات مثبتة
ومناعة قطيع ويقولون أن ذلك
قد يستغرق سنة أخرى أو نحو ذلك بريان تود
سي إن إن واشنطن